two more New England states are moving
to join Massachusetts in allowing the
legal sale marijuana lawmakers in
Vermont and Maine are working on
regulations so people can buy pot from
licensed vendors the use of recreational
marijuana is already legal in both
states recreational pot sales officially
began in Massachusetts yesterday Tony de
copal is at a store where you can buy it
in Leicester Massachusetts Tony good
morning good morning and welcome to
cultivate where more than a thousand
people came through here yesterday for
day one
marijuana purchases the most popular
item a string called chocolate OG now if
you're thinking that looks a lot
stronger than the stuff I remember
you're probably right and sales are
booming the first to licensed pot shops
in Massachusetts opened on Tuesday with
high excitement and long lines thousands
waited as much as five hours I'm 64
years old and I used to have to run from
the cops when I bought pot in in the
past so I figured I wanted to do it
legally
for the first time inside cultivate
customers were presented with a daily
menu selection with varieties including
Tropicana cookies and purple punch but
it's not cheap one ounce of raw bud at
cultivate cost four hundred and twenty
dollars got a couple good things way too
many edibles I am going home and I am
going to be enjoying them with my
grandmother it's like your coffee in the
morning it's like your coffee in the
morning and not like your wine at night
you know it can be pulled Sam barber is
cultivates president and co-owner you
know there is a lot of wrong information
going out there about this product
and again it is about doing it like
anything in a safe balanced way that's
helping people think this has actually
gone through some kind of safety and
efficacy that we even know what it is it
hasn't Kevin Sabet is a former White
House drug policy adviser and president
of smart approaches to marijuana you're
relying on a state that is being heavily
influenced by the marijuana industry
themselves to basically tell you that
your product is safe Colorado has seen
hundreds of thousands of individual
products recalled because of additives
and other kinds of bacteria and molds
that are in these marijuana products so
it's really buyer beware but that's not
scaring away consumers the number of
Americans reporting daily or almost
daily marijuana use jumped from a little
over three million in 2002 to just over
eight million in 2017 this isn't about
the individual users this is about a
green light to an industry that is
taking all of their place from Big
Tobacco that lied to the American people
for almost a century why would we get
fooled again
and speaking of sales here in
Massachusetts by one estimate sales
could reach a billion and a half dollars
of course no telling if and when federal
legalization could come through but
Americans already consume about three
times as much cannabis as the global
average Gail yes they like it in America
got some happy people in Massachusetts
thank you very much Tony good to see you